أعلنت الشركة الأكثر قيمة في العالم
للتو عن أرقامها المالية
للربع الأول ، وشاهدت شركة النفط العملاقة أرامكو السعودية
المملوكة للسعودية
انخفاض أرباحها بنحو 25٪
خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية ، حيث
تسبب فيروس كورونا وحرب الأسعار مع روسيا
في دفع التكلفة.  من برميل من النفط إلى
السقوط الحر ، لذلك دعونا نجلب محرر الأسواق الناشئة في سي إن إن
جون ديف تراس
في أبو ظبي ، ينضم إلينا الآن يعيش جيدًا
لرؤيتك يا جون ، وكذلك فعلت النتائج التي
ترقى إلى مستوى التوقعات مع هذا الانحدار
الحاد والأرباح جيدًا كما تعلمون إكليل الجبل
لأنه  من حالة اللعب في
سوق الطاقة في الوقت الحالي ، قيل
إن المعيار منخفض جدًا بالنسبة لأرامكو وهذه
فترة غير عادية تمامًا
لأنها أول نتائج ربع سنوية لها
كشركة مساهمة عامة
ذهبت إلى الاكتتاب العام في نهاية
2019 كما يجب أن تشير إليه هنا ،
فقد جاءوا بنسبة 25 ٪ عند 16 نقطة وسبعة
مليارات دولار مقابل توقعات
بشيء أعلى بنحو مليار دولار
ولكن هذه المرة  في العام الماضي ، حققوا أكثر من
20 مليار دولار ، لكنهم كسبوا الأموال
مرة أخرى في هذا الربع ، فإن
شركات النفط العالمية التي لا تستطيع الوصول إلى
هذا العرض الرخيص من المعروض الوفير من
النفط الخام لا تحقق أرباحًا في الوقت الحالي ، على
سبيل المثال في الولايات المتحدة
حيث تتواجد  تسريح العمال
ليس هو الحال مع أرامكو في هذه المرحلة ولكن
هذه الفوضى التي تحدثت عنها في
مارس مع فيروس كورونا ضرب
الطلب بنحو 30 مليون برميل يوميًا
في أبريل ثم حرب الأسعار التي
حدثت مع المملكة العربية السعودية وروسيا
والولايات المتحدة التي  لن نشعر به
حتى الربع الثاني ، لذا فإن
الأرباع الحالية في الوقت الحالي
وستكون النتائج في وقت لاحق في
أشهر الصيف مروعة
لنسميها كما هي لأن لدينا
أسعارًا سلبية في أبريل ونحن
تحوم حول 30 دولارًا للبرميل في الوقت الحالي ،
وهذا لا يملأ
خزائن الدولة التي حققوا فيها 88 مليار دولار
في عام 2019
بالكامل وتم دفع 73 مليار دولار كأرباح للمملكة
لذا ، ما هو نوع الضغط الذي يمارسه
هذا السعر اليوم ليس فقط على المملكة
العربية السعودية ولكن على جميع المنتجين العرب الآخرين ،
نعم أعتقد أنها نقطة تستحق
التأكيد عليها لأن الجميع يقول جيدًا
أن
العصارات منخفضة التكلفة لا تزال تجني الكثير من المال
ولكن ميزانياتها  دول
مثل المملكة العربية السعودية ، والإمارات العربية المتحدة ، والكويت في
الخليج ، إنه يهز منتجًا رئيسيًا هنا
في الشرق الأوسط ، حيث كانوا يعيشون على
أسعار تزيد عن 60 دولارًا للبرميل
للمعيار الدولي العام الماضي ، نحن
نتطلع الآن إلى 30 دولارًا في المتوسط الآن ، وربما مت
سط  السعر 35 هذا العام الذي
تبحث عنه حوالي النصف من حيث
الإيرادات للبلدان نتيجة لذلك
، اتخذ ولي العهد الأمير محمد بن
سلمان ما يُنظر إليه على أنه إجراءات جذرية
بين عشية وضحاها من خلال الإعلان عن حقيقة أنه
يضاعف ضريبة v80 بنسبة 15٪ ثلاث مرات.
لقد كان عمره عامين قد
قضى على استحقاقات موظفي الحكومة
التي كانت تساوي حوالي 300 دولار شهريًا
من حيث تعديل تكلفة المعيشة
ذهب شقيقه الأكبر عبد العزيز كان
البعض على ص.  طلب وزير الطاقة
اقتطاعًا آخر بمقدار مليون
برميل ، لذا فإن إكليل الجبل من حرب الأسعار تلك
وإنتاج اثني عشر فاصلًا وثلاثة
ملايين برميل انخفض الإنتاج الضخم إلى
حوالي سبعة ملايين ونصف المليون برميل
اليوم ، مما أدى إلى قطع حوالي خمسة مليارات
برميل وبمدى أقل من  شهرين
عصيبين للغاية وقرارات صعبة للغاية
قادمة من المملكة العربية السعودية ، كان القرار
بشأن v80 مقلقًا للغاية هنا في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، وقالت وزارة المالية إننا
لن نفعل الشيء نفسه ، فهناك
القليل من الذعر بسبب انخفاض
أسعار النفط في جميع أنحاء منطقة الشرق الأوسط